for the socks kevin polar in the
lead-off spot against a lefty wade
leblanc gave a five-run run gonna be
patient with him
oh one he goes after that one drives a
high one deep into left center mullins
back and it gets over the wall for a
home run a lead-off shot by kevin pillar
and just like that the red sox leaded
one to nothing now he got that cut
fastball up in the zone and pilate
jumped all over his third home run of
the season his second this season off
leblanc christian vasquez now steps in
leblanc this is outside with her
and now
something is apparently wrong for
leblanc here come
a few members of the orioles coaching
and training staff after leblanc threw
ball one to vasquez there is an
unfortunately early meeting on the mount
a brand new orioles pitcher in the first
inning wade leblanc threw just 14
pitches he called for mark shires the
assistant trainer and orioles coaches
and here's thomas eschmann ben couple of
swinging strikes of one two
and chavis goes down swinging on three
straights eshelman strands a pair
guidely facing the orioles for the first
time this season he had no decision his
last timeout
mullins with a shout out to right field
jd martinez is playing there and he's
not gonna get this
mullins races to second and he will pump
the brakes there a leadoff double for
the new leadoff man
swinging into miss he went outside the
strike zone to tag by plucky to complete
the k and they're two away 0-2
and a breaking ball freezes valencia for
strike three it was an arduous first for
godly but it was also a scoreless one
ryan mount castle with a rope off the
glove of rafi el divers into left field
mount castle will head for two pallara's
throw is not in time
ryan mount castle's got his first extra
base hit as a big leaguer now that's
what we expect payoff pitch runner first
on the loose and swung on and missed and
he gets out of it again this time
stranding two
3-0
and a miss low a sliding stop from
plawecki ball four three walks now loads
the bases for the orioles again here
jeffrey springs into the ball game right
now recall yesterday from the alternate
side second major league stint this
season he will face rio ruiz where the
bases loaded two down
ruiz into right field martinez was
shaded toward right center and that's
down to score at least two
mount castle pumps the brakes at third
severino and cisco are in
and rio ruiz delivers where the base is
loaded a two-run single and the orioles
have the lead switch hitter switches
over to the right side velasquez lays
down a two out but springs has no play
beautifully done by velasquez some two
out small ball for the o's
and he bunts in mount castle for the
innings third run
another bomb as ronaldo nunez called
them
this ball is tagged the other way and
the hit streak is at 18 for santander
on his way and in at second with another
extra base hit his 11th double of the
season and 22nd extra base hit to lead
the major leagues
3-2 and went after it that was up and
out of the zone and he is one angry
hitter nunez breaking the bat in
frustration
as he went chasing on a pitch way up and
out of the strike zone
3-2
swung on and missed he put him away
so good job by springs pitching around
the lead-off double
here's ryan mount castle
well he went down to dig that ball out
hooks it fair into the corner
and mount castle has a double double day
well he knows all about doubles he had
35 of them last year in triple a as he
won the triple a mvp in the
international league try again with a
1-2
and got him to chase so ruiz strikes out
tua
miguel castro
enters the game for the second day in a
row
speaking of movement that was a nasty
change of dirty 93 sandra bogart steps
in
down the line that one headed toward the
wall
leaping up he can't get it
that's gonna bounce around in the corner
and jd martinez
winds up down there at third base as
xander bogarts nearly hit the ball out
of the ballpark
here's vasquez
ground ball to second base valenca is
going to come home martinez is out
a perfect throw by valenka a slow runner
at martinez the right ingredients were
there for the second out at the plate
and got him looking that was perfect
been fun to watch that one rocketed that
one headed for the
wall right back to pillar he's going to
come up gunning
here's the throw into second base and he
is out he cut him down
nunez out and maybe a little nicked up
but he is certainly out courtesy of
pilar driven in one
sharply on the ground diving play ruiz
from his knees to second and rio saves
another
he is as good as it gets over at third
base right now rio ruiz
on 3-2 severino serves one up the middle
it's fielded by jackie bradley right
around where severino hit the ball
yesterday and he was a little bit laid
out of the box there he limped a little
bit and now the orioles are going to
check on him
he's coming out and brian holliday
will come in
in the air to left pilar was very
shallow didn't get a great jump but it's
over his glove
to the wall to score two more
ruiz is into second with a double he's
knocked in four runs in the game you
know these red sox outfitters and pilar
was playing very shallow in right field
yesterday a bunch and he gets burnt
right here
jackie is old for three
up to buffalo that one driven the other
way that's a shot williams backing up to
the wall and it's gone jackie bradley jr
with a two-run homer as he goes opposite
field and hold the phone here it's a 5-4
ball game jackie hanging in there tough
against the lefty kevin pilar started
this game with a home run
can he end it with an outs
perhaps he can velasquez to second
and the orioles
survive five to four tanner scott does
get that first big league save